oh we are now highly successful with
with about twenty percent of cancer fur
in fact initially you know we can do
something the problem is the cancers
tend to get more dangerous and resistant
to chemotherapy and today we postpone a
lot of deaths from cancer but we don't
finally prevent enough of them so that
if there was no cancer research 700,000
Americans of dying cancer area today
600,000 a lot of them lid no more now
and that's good I'd like to move to a
situation where you know we only lose a
hundred thousand each it is we want it
enough I think a real chance we can move
to such a situation over the next decade
well up to now we've been focusing out
sort of the organized cell were called
the epithelial cell most human cancers
are tissues lining glands and their
nightly touching each other so liquids
don't you know pass through the membrane
cetera but then there are other cells in
our body which are are not tightly
organized and full da we call the
mesenchymal and most cancers for
progressed toward a mesenchymal form
which up to now we've not very
successfully treated but I think we I
think there's the whole boards my hope
their words we know there are many
different forms of cancer to start with
you all progressed towards something
similar it says similar to a stem cell
differentiates themselves so that the if
you're killed by prostate cancer it may
be not that different than me you're
dying from lung cancer or melanoma that
is this the bad cells have roughly the
same biochemistry underlying
biochemistry and so if we could kill one
of the sort of a sort of terminal stage
cancer we might be able to do all but
anyways that's my hope I know there are
a few other people think my way but the
slogan you get now is you all going to
be genetically different and we'll have
to use personalized therapy but before I
was treated I'd like my DNA to be looked
at but the best way to finally
sure we not to focus on the unique
features but features common to all
cancer cells